time's celebrated it's 100 most
influential people at a New York City
gala the group of world leaders
philanthropists and artists honored last
night were more diverse than ever
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn was on the red carpet 100
artists pioneers icons times most
influential people who've made an impact
across the globe like gretchen carlson
whose sexual harassment allegation
against former fox news chief roger
ailes brought the troubling issue to the
forefront it takes tremendous courage
for women to know that they can stand up
and speak up and have a positive result
something these four women did when they
launched the Woman's March bringing
millions across the nation to the
streets we never really stopped after
January 21st we've been building this
march into a movement of women and
allies all across the country in the
world my mom always says capture
someone's heart and you capture their
mind and I think moonlight that picture
this year really did that so kudos to
Barry Jenkins I spoke to the moonlight
filmmaker and he reflected on the
infamous Oscars flub I think it's
wonderful that we get to celebrate two
phones instead of just one but there is
one name on the trophy
inside demi lovato who was honored for
speaking out about mental illness
performed an emotional rendition of her
hit confident
[Music]
Viola Davis gave a heartfelt toast to
fellow honorees I lift the glass to
everyone in this room everyone who has
decided to live a life bigger than
yourself and I applaud you and I am
honored to be in this room with you
thank you notably absent from the room
five members of the Trump administration
including the president who were named
on the list are Charlie Rose summed up
the event and the people being honored
but I think they try to reflect a sense
of the community at large in terms of
media in terms of male/female in terms
of diversity in terms of regional
diversity I feel like the time 100 is
like dinner Charlie Rose oh yes it is
except the menu is pizza hamburger the
list of honorees included more
controversial figures this year than in
the years past like North Korean leader
Kim jong-un and WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange times editor-in-chief Nancy
Gibbs called it complicated saying there
was a different kind of depth and
dimension in their thinking this year so
you know it's what you I think both of
you said this on the red carpet it's not
necessarily the people that you like or
the people that you admire it's those
people that are the most influent and
they always say who do you want to meet
and you don't want to make the obvious
you want to make people that you don't
necessarily know right there was a guy
last night from Syria he was head of the
white helmets yeah beautifully elephant
right or Fattah been Sudha she's the
Gambian former Gambian justice minister
she's now head of the ICC Investigations
Unit or the woman who is fighting
against Rodrigo Duterte he's on the list
the Philippines president but she's a
human rights activist filling it but
those of the interested speaking it's a
great mix it's good to see you but it
was good to see you dress was amazing
right charlie you're not the only person
to tell her right that Nora the hike was
worth it and the purse in the first five
days and the fifth I know what the fifth
oh my god